if you could travel faster than the
speed of light where would you go Mars
the nearest star system or to distant
stars in far galaxies does faster than
light travel have its limits
this is what if and here's what would
happen if we had working warp drive
technology for all we know nothing can
travel faster than life light speed
seems to be the universal speed limit
for everything that's moving in space
unless we build a spaceship capable of
distorting space-time a spaceship
equipped with warp drive our craft would
be encased by a large ring that would
compress space-time in front of the
spaceship and expand it to the rear of
it it wouldn't be the spacecraft moving
over the cosmic speed limit it would be
space-time itself moving around the
spacecraft once we figured out this
method of propulsion we could start our
cosmic conquest how far into the
vastness of the universe would we make
it if the warp drive could accelerate
our spacecraft to the speed of 10 times
faster than the speed of light it would
only take us about 75 seconds to get to
Mars it would take even less time to get
from the earth to the Sun some 50
seconds of space travel and there's our
star right in front of our eyes from
there we'd speed to the inner limits of
the Oort cloud the beginning of the edge
of our solar system at 10 times the
speed of light we'd get there in about
72 days after 83 more days in space we'd
arrive at Alpha Centauri a star system
that hosts the potentially habitable
exoplanet Proxima Centauri our very
first interstellar colony would settle
on Proxima Centauri but humanity won't
stop exploring our next stop would be
the Gliese 667c see the hotter and
bigger version of Earth about 23 and a
half light-years away
this exoplanet might not turn out to be
too hospitable but it could be worth
sending a crew on the four-and-a-half
year round trip to check it out
other manned crafts would take on trips
to Kepler for four to be and kepler-452b
the next exoplanets on our list of
potentially habitable worlds those
spacecraft would have to speed up a
little unless they wanted to spend over
a hundred and twenty years in space
covering a distance of over 1,200
light-years at a speed of 1,000 times
faster than the speed of light they'd
only need about four hundred and thirty
seven days to reach those kepler
exoplanets yeah
even when surpassing the light speed
limit we'd still have to spend years
traveling across space searching out
other habitable worlds and their
inhabitants if there are any the
universe is big very big and it keeps
expanding we'd never be able to travel
to the edge of it even with working warp
drive our home galaxy the Milky Way is
about two hundred thousand light-years
across
even if we could achieve the speed of
one Lightyear per hour it would take us
22 years to reach the outmost corner of
our own galaxy let's come back down to
earth for a moment the fastest space
probe we've ever come up with is ninety
million times slower than our
hypothesized Lightspeed spacecraft we've
got a long way to go to achieve a star
trek level of interstellar travel and
don't forget that using warp drive
technology would require an enormous
amount of energy in the first place
maybe we should start investing our
resources into building a Dyson Sphere
around the Sun to fill all our energy
demands once and for all but that's a
story for another what if
[Music]
[Applause]